Mostanában sokat gondolkozom azon, hogy
hogyan lehetne az AI-t hatékonyabb
oktatásra használni. Nem tudom ti hogy
működtök, de én sokkal könnyebben
tanulok meg valamit, hogyha az érdekel
is engem. Ilyen szempontból a
kíváncsiságom hajt előre, nem pedig az,
hogy a következő fejezet éppen mit
tartalmazzna. Milyen lenne egy olyan
platform, ahol az AI feladata az, hogy
megtudja, hogy engem mi érdekel, és a
következő fejezetet ő javasolja. És
ilyen szempontból nem lineárisan
haladnánk előre a tananyagban, vagyis
nem az első fejezet után a második
fejezet jönne, hanem tegyük fel a
nyolcadik, utána a 16, utána vissza a
harmadik fejezet, és így össze-vissza
kalandoznánk a tananyagba. Az én
feladatom az lenne, hogy figyeljek,
figyeljek arra, hogy mi az, ami engem
érdekel. Az AI feladata pedig az, hogy
amire a végére érek a tananyagnak, addig
mindent lefedjünk, ami szükséges.